Hello YouTube.
This is CZ speaking.
With the release of the new Death Note movie
on Netflix *clear throat* OK I'm not going
to keep up that voice for the entire video.
But anyways, here are The Things You Missed
in Death Note.
The very first episode of Things You Missed
was an episode on the trailer for this movie
and now it's finally been released.
One of the biggest complaints I saw about
this movie on Twitter was the lack of the
iconic potato chip scene.
However, it may have actually been referenced
in a small way at a couple different points
in the film.
Mia Sutton is seen eating some potato chips
in Light's room, then he goes over to the
desk and it's covered in crumbs!!
So maybe the scene did take place "off camera"
so to speak.
Did anyone else think when Light got caught
with the homework pages that it was strange
that she found those, but not the Death Note?
I just imagine her thought process: you may
have this book that's capable of killing 1000s
of people, and that's fine, but boy if you
cheat in my class I will mess you up!
It's even more ridiculous considering that
there have actually been instances of kids
getting in trouble for having fake Death Notes
in schools before.
I attempted to read each page of the Death
Note, but motion blur and Netflix's streaming
quality made it kind of hard, but here's what
I picked up.
This page says something about Suicide and
Scarlet Fever.
Light Turner is not the first one to have
the Death Note and all the previous pages
and names are already in there.
Some of them were historical figures, others
just seemed to be names.
This guy Jean Chabot was a Canadian legislator
in the 1800s.
Michel Claparede was a French general in the
1700s.
Charles Adrien Merode was a nobleman in Europe,
and I believe the name is also French.
In fact, it seems that the Death Note spent
quite a lot of time in France.
The next page contains Louis Chabot, Michel
Claparede again, with something crossed out,
and Andre Massena, a French Military commander.
So I'm thinking one Light's predecessors used
the Death Note as a political weapon in ancient
France.
Can you say spin-off?
Before we continue, I need to set the record
straight on this apple thing.
For some reason, in this movie, Ryuk does
not, eat the center of the apple.
If you're a Death Note fan, you know that
apple cores are a myth, they don't exist,
it all just apple.
Don't believe me?
Let me demonstrate.
🎵🎵
Another thing I found strange: nobody questions
the destroyed classroom?
This seems like a bigger deal than helping
some kids cheat on their test, but it never
comes up again.
As Light goes to the window, some text reading:
The World, is written on the wall.
Is that because it's a classroom and classrooms
have maps of the world?
Yes.
But could it be a reference to the song title
of the first OP of Death Note?
🎵Hirogaru yami no naka kawashiatta 🎵
Maybe.
Probably not.
In this movie, Light lives with his Dad, so
unfortunately we do not get to see Mrs. Yagami
or Sayu.
We actually find out that Light's mom was
killed.
I had assumed that it was earlier in his life,
but she's still around in this picture on
Light's 16th birthday, so it must be very
recent.
Now in the anime and manga, the Gods of Death
come from the Shinigami Realm, which is not
seen any of the films.
Unless you count the relights, but those are
just the anime cut down into the length of
a film, so that should not count.
Although we don't see the Shinigami Realm
in this movie, that doesn't mean it doesn't
exist.
I noticed Rule 65 in the notebook makes reference
to the Shinigami Realm.
It would also appear that the 19 day rule
is still in effect.
If you aren't familiar with it, it allows
you to write the cause of death before the
name, so long as you do fill in the name within
19 days.
Also, the 490 days you get to to maintain
ownership of the Death Note without possessing
it has been shortened to 7 in this movie,
and for no good reason because it never comes
up.
In this scene Light tries to get Mia to see
Ryuk by having her touch the notebook, which
works in the anime, but not in this movie
apparently.
So what I'm wondering is, where did he get
the idea to try that?
Did Light watch the anime or read the manga?
Do those things exist in the world of this
movie?
Kind of.
The Brode hostage situation takes place in
Little Tokyo in Seattle, which is just a little
reference to Japan, and there a few in this
film, like how Light tries to make it seem
like he is in Japan by adopting the Kira moniker
(again, did he watch the anime?) and making
many of his early killings in Japan.
We are going to start getting into spoilers
for the anime and the movie now, this is your
final warning.
Remember in my initial video how I speculated
that Mia Sutton was the US version of Misa
Misa?
Well, Mia has an eye on her window, which
is interesting considering that Misa obtains
the Shinigami eyes in the manga, and she is
basically the eyes of Kira.
In the movie, there are no Shinigami eyes,
but she does at times play the hand of Kira,
which is what Mikami does in the manga.
The song that Watari sings to L is from the
Wizard of Oz.
It plays when they skip through the flowers
toward Emerald City.
I'll talk more about the significance of flowers
in this Death Note movie, later in this video.
Detective Turner has a list of murders that
he suspects to be Kira murders in his office.
Some of them are kind of funny, and there
are very few heart attacks compared to Light
Yagami.
Here are a few examples.
Eaten by Thylacine.
Attacked by bullshark.
Crushed by crystal chandelier.
Falling to death.
Electrocuted while playing guitar in the bath.
There were a few interesting things that L
has, one of which is a golden apple, the other
appears to be a puzzle cube type thing.
If Mia Sutton is a combination of Misa and
Mikami, maybe L is a combination of L and
Near.
The Lind L Taylor scene is skipped over in
favor of L directly confronting Light.
He claims: "I shall be meeting you face to
face very shortly."
Which he does.
In a really short scene, Light notices this
guy following him, who is basically Raye Penber.
His name in this movie is Raymond Young.
In the anime, Light goes on a date with his
classmate Yuri to Spaceworld, which is a Japanese
amusement park, in an attempt to out the identity
of Raye Penber on the bus.
In this movie, he takes Mia on a date to this
attraction on Pier 57, where they address
how the stalker should be dealt with, so I
guess it's supposed to be the same scene.
That's not how L holds a phone.
This is how L holds a phone.
It seems strange that some of his other mannerisms
from the anime carried over to Stanfield's
L, but not this others.
I guess Watari, is just W's full name in this
movie.
Light writes "Watari" in the Death Note and
it works.
In the manga, his real name is Quillish Wammy.
This is probably my favorite entry in the
Death Note.
The guy's name is Abdul Aswad, and the cause
of Death.
Eats a grenade.
EATS A GRENADE.
At this point, I don't understand why doesn't
Light just burn the page himself?
That would be the first thing I would do.
If you haven't noticed, this movie is nowhere
near as smart as it's Japanese counterpart.
If you haven't seen those movies, I would
highly recommend you check out Death Note
and Death Note II: The Last Name.
I can't say the same for the spin-off sequel,
L: Change the World.
This video is not sponsored.
Both the first and last major Kira killings
happen in front of a florist.
When Mia dies, she lands right in this bed
of flowers, leading me to believe that flowers
are somehow representative of death.
If flowers are death, than butterflies are
an agent of death, or a spreader of death.
We see butterflies constantly being associated
with Mia: in her room, in her locker, a butterfly
balloon hovering next to her when she is reunited
with Light close to the end.
If you noticed any other references, let me
know in the comments.
If you want to have your very own Death Note,
leave a like on this video.
Tomorrow, the 27th, we are doing a new Deadstream,
at 2PM Pacific.
That's 5PM Eastern, 10PM British Summer Time.
We would love to have you join us, it'll be
right here on CZsWorld.
If you're new to the channel, I am a filmmaker.
I make horror.
I talk about horror.
So if you like horror be sure to subscribe
to the channel for new horrors every week,
ring that deathbell for notifications and
I'll see you tomorrow in The Deadstream.
Assuming we both survive.